hey youtubers its charlie so big news
they've cast a whole bunch of new people
for the spider-man homecoming movie we
kind of know who the villains are gonna
be Michael Keaton is probably going to
be playing the vulture so there's gonna
be a breakdown of all that they're about
five or six new actors that they've cast
in various roles people that are going
to be friends in and around Peter Parker
the villain characters some of them we
have a pretty good idea of who they're
playing or they've already said exactly
who they're playing and some are a
little more vague like Donald Glover for
instance a lot of people were like oh is
he going to be playing Miles Morales no
way he would be like five o'clock shadow
Miles Morales he's way too old Miles
Morales is more of a little brother to
Peter Parker and the grand scheme of
things so if Peter Parker's gonna be
like a sophomore at high school when
this movie picks up Miles Morales would
still be in junior high he'd be like a
really really little kid but let's talk
about the vulture so the reason people
think that Michael Keaton is playing the
vulture is really like all the trades
have started a rapport Michael Keaton
who may be playing the vulture and when
the Hollywood trade newspapers start
talking about stuff like that it's a
pretty sure bet that that's the way it's
gonna go down but here's the reason why
people think that he's playing the
vulture and it has to do with who the
secondary villains gonna be so Michael
Keaton's gonna be playing the main
villain but there's going to be another
slightly smaller villain working with
him in the movie that's gonna be played
by Logan marshal green and he's supposed
to be playing the tinkerer and the
really interesting thing about his
character is that he helped the vulture
create his flight suit using shatori
tech so there you have your Marvel
Cinematic Universe obviously we've
already seen spider-man in Civil War so
we've already seen Marvel Cinematic
Universe crossover with the Sony
franchise but this just deepens that it
makes sense that if a whole bunch of
alien tech gets left behind after a big
invasion villains are gonna try and
seize the opportunity so Logan Marshall
Green's tinkerer character is going to
be someone who's playing around with
that and even though we don't know what
Michael Keaton's arc is and it felt like
why the vulture is doing something that
spider-man is trying to stop like he has
to have something that he wants so that
he can be like okay I don't care who I
killed to get this thing or whatever the
MacGuffin is we just know that Peter
Parker will try to stop him that'll be
the big win of the film defeating the
villain and then making it to class on
time on Monday remember he's in high
school so a lot of the new characters
that they've announced our high school
characters they've cast his principal it
looks like Michelle Gonzalez is going to
be his love entry
which I like is a nice twist they're not
going back to the gwen stacy pool mary
jane just because we've already done
that so many times they're in there like
all the characters that Spiderman has
ever interacted with in the comics
they're totally in the universe issues
that this first movie that they're doing
with Tom Holland they wanted to feel as
fresh as possible which is why they're
going with a villain that they never
used before like the vulture in the
supporting cast that haven't been
featured as much like Michelle Gonzalez
and even the actor who's in like the
Flash Thompson like the bully role who
was actually played by Joe Manganiello
in the original spider-man films which i
think is kind of funny he's not gonna be
Flash Thompson because every single
movie was spider-man the last couple of
years has featured Flash Thompson as the
high school bully so I'm really excited
they're not just doing the exact same
thing but obviously you know Tony Stark
is gonna be in the film he's not gonna
be a main character
he'll probably be featured less than he
was during civil war but he'll probably
be an important part of whatever the
MacGuffin is like something Spiderman
needs to help him defeat the vulture
Tony Stark will be there to offer advice
and a few toys because what does Tony
Stark good for if not creating new toys
the other new person they just announced
is Martin Starr we have no idea who he's
playing he might be playing a villain he
might be there for a comedic relief it's
like a Donald Glover situation they were
probably cast because they can do both
drama and comedy so we don't know
exactly who they're playing only that
they're gonna get to be funny a little
bit serious in the film which i think is
totally the appropriate way to use those
two actors even if the people they're
playing aren't gonna be really big comic
book characters but if you're wondering
if the movie is doing a specific comic
book story it's not
it'll be an adaptation just like all the
other Marvel movies if you remember Iron
Man 3 did extremest it was very
different from the way that's used in
the comics it didn't get embedded in
Iron Man skin he didn't get hijacked by
Ultron like so many things get changed
about the comics when they make the
movies it's gonna be the same thing with
the new spider-man movies and it is
gonna be a trilogy but the first movie
isn't going to overburden itself with
trying to set up a big spider-man
universe in the way the previous Andrew
Garfield Sony movies were doing remember
how amazing spider-man 2 tried to tease
sinister 6 and that didn't really play
out there's still a venom movie that
Sony's trying to make so there's still
like sinister six venom things happening
at Sony it's just that they're not as
big a deal as they used to be in the
priority now
it's just keeping spider-man folded into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so Sony
isn't trying to create its own cinematic
universe with just spider-man characters
it's trying to integrate with Marvel's
the reason that's a really good thing is
because they don't have to set up ten
other movies in this one spider-man
movie they're making which I think will
be a much more enjoyable experience but
let me know in the comments what do you
think about Michael Keaton playing the
vulture I know if you haven't seen
Birdman you have to watch Birdman it's
such a great parody of all the Batman
stuff that he's done it's a great parody
of big Hollywood actors and big
Hollywood franchises in general but
Michael Keaton takes every opportunity
to make fun of his time as Batman and
what do you think about the vulture you
know like his flight suit being made
based on something that was set up in
the Avengers movie I feel like they're
just trying to tie this into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as much as possible
and it would totally make sense that if
you're gonna have an advanced flight
suit based on alien tech that that tech
might have come from the shatori
invasion so even if it's a bummer that
the Marvel TV shows haven't bled into
the movies that much yet even the
Netflix characters haven't crossed over
yet at least everything is connected in
the movie universe like you have
callbacks to the very first Avengers
film
I don't know that Sony is gonna be
bringing any spider-man homecoming stuff
to comic-con but if they do I'll totally
do a video for it mostly Marvel is gonna
be hyping up guardians of the galaxy to
Doctor Strange they might tease some
other things I feel like they'll bring a
little bit of spider-man stuff so
because so much stuff has been announced
the last couple of days I'm gonna be
doing a flash season 3 video next be
sure to subscribe to get that I'll do a
Civil War 2 video and then like an arrow
Season 5 video after that so that'll all
post this weekend before a game of
Thrones stuff comes back but there's a
lot of really awesome stuff happening
and if you want to read comic books
based on spider-man stories I would
recommend you just start with what's
going on right now in and around Civil
War 2 do not worry about reading the old
spider-man stuff just read what's
happening right now just jump on the
summer hype train and have some fun
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my guardians
of the galaxy to Comic Con teaser and
you can click here for the Game of
Thrones episode 9 trailer that's coming
this weekend thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you